foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people
we help people build wealth we help you
do work that you love and we help you
create actual amazing relationships
thank you for being with us America
we're here to help open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today and we're here to talk
with you about you right in front of you
Tony's going to start off this hour in
Minneapolis hey Tony welcome to the
Ramsay show
I gave an honored to talk to you Jade
great addition to the show thank you so
much for taking my call
great
um my mother
talked to me this weekend about redoing
her will and she asked me if she thought
it was a good idea
to have the lawyer be the executor of
the will
and the reason she's asking is we don't
really trust my sister
she uh sued my Stepmother's estate and
won that case
because we were excluded from the her
will
so I don't know what to do I don't want
to deal with the
legal ramifications once my mom passes
if my sister chooses to do that
wow I'm sorry what a painful mess
nothing brings out family dysfunction
like a good death oh my gosh
so in a normal world where you don't
have a litigious crazy sister you would
um
you you would say Okay executor the word
if you look at it carefully simply means
to execute
execute your mother's wishes her last
her will what she Wills to happen what
her and she writes it down called a
testament her last will and testament so
you're going to execute her wishes uh
but if you got somebody that's going to
screw around with that and fight all the
time uh not a bad idea to have a lawyer
in the mix just to keep her at Bay it
might it might intimidate her into
behaving
okay I didn't and you wouldn't have to
mess with her
exactly that's the plus side of it I
haven't talked to her in two years since
she started the lawsuit yeah what's the
uh what's the size of the estate
I don't know I asked her to do what you
recommended and have a reading of the
will and my mom said
she that would pretty much end the
relationship between her and my sister
so because she wants to break it up by
percentages like if you had to guess how
much you don't know the size I mean 10
million one million hundred thousand I'm
guessing I'm guessing maybe 500 to a
million okay
uh my guess is the attorney's probably
gonna charge her 20 grand
okay uh give or take I mean he might
charge less or she might charge more
might charge less but um wouldn't be
that unusual uh that's a and then an
hourly rate if it goes beyond that
because we end up in court or something
right so
um but a flat fee to be an Executor on a
state that size you know somewhere in
there I could be off but just ask and
find out about that uh but here's the
thing I think we what you're describing
to me is you got a real high percentage
you've got to deal with crazy sister
right
yep so why I don't want that no thanks
Mom get a lawyer
okay good and that part's on a great I
just didn't know
if we could even trust the lawyer pardon
well you can't answer
you can yeah you can't trust any I mean
lawyers are people some of them are
better than others at their job
and so your mom's job is to get in there
and learn
uh what the attorney that the attorneys
put everything down right and talk to
the attorney about it and go okay this
you know crazy is going to come at us
when I die come at you so you need to
have this thing buttoned up buddy now
what's but not mean what extra layers do
we need to put in this thing to totally
insulate it now here's the thing in
America anyone can sue anyone for
anything
even if they completely make it up
okay we have this idea that somehow you
have to tell the truth or something in a
lawsuit uh you don't
there's a thing called a pleading which
is when they file the lawsuit and they
put down their version of the story and
uh when you're dealing with crazy people
their version of story is mostly lies
and it becomes public record
so she could say you know you did all
these horrible things in her pleading
and file that law so regardless of what
this will says a will doesn't keep her
from filing it just keeps her from
wanting to file because it's so airtight
but yeah you you may get drugged through
the mud anyway there's nothing and
honestly there's nothing you can do
about it
I guess she's the executor on her
current will but she wants to update it
and that's where your sister is the
executor in her current will
okay and she's not in good relationship
with her yeah she does need to change
that yesterday
yep
yeah I know
she's not a very good person but she's
very intimidating too so
how quickly do you think she's gonna
actually make this change
I'm hoping by Summer
okay how old's your mom
76.
uh end of March dude
okay get it done by the end of March
because you're going to end up but you
tangled up and stuff for a decade
screwing around with intimidating crazy
sister
now I like her even less
she's a bull she's a bully
yes yeah
so um there's no amount of money here
that's worth putting up with somebody
like that so yeah your mom needs to have
yes yes yes yes I normally don't tell
people to have a logger be the executor
but in this case it might be a deterrent
because the attorney is not as easily
he's not or she's not affected At All by
the emotions of your sister where you
are that's right and I feel like if he's
the executor even though it though you
know the mom created the will if he's
the executor sister is going to take it
out on him regardless just because he's
in that position whereas with the lawyer
it's a little bit more of a I don't know
he's like Switzerland in that situation
yeah you know so maybe it can preserve
some of I mean they're dysfunctional but
maybe there's something that can be
preserved there by having the lawyer do
it it'd be nice but it doesn't sound
like it all right Kelsey's ship sailed
Kelsey's in Lynchburg Virginia hi Kelsey
how are you
oh Dave I'm better than I deserve how
are you better than I deserve what's up
so I'm 26 currently engaged we are cash
flowing our wedding and a baby step two
um I have been at my job as a social
worker for a year making forty thousand
dollars and I recently graduated with my
master's degree
I feel like I've added value
um with the knowledge that I've gained
from my degree how should I go about
asking my boss for a pay increase
well you know if I were asking for an
increase I would start with not just
saying hey I've got these credentials
here's what I deserve I would probably
go in asking and in checking myself
first and going okay I may have upgraded
my career but have I actually added
value so it starts with having a
conversation with your leader about what
value you can add what that looks like
in talking about what a long-term plan
can look like as opposed to kind of
marching in there and saying I deserve
yeah that's exactly right switch shoes
and say if you were sitting in your
boss's seat how would you want to hear
this conversation coming from that
person and it generally is a lot of
humility and it's like gosh I finished
my degree I'm so excited about that I'm
doing all these other things here I want
to keep adding value what could I do
here that would cause you to give me a
raise
how can I help how can I help that kind
of an approach very few people are angry
about that this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
our question of the day comes from Ryan
in Arkansas Jay do you want to take it
I'll take it he says I'm 45 years old
I'm married with two children under 12
and completely debt free I took a new
job a year and a half ago making 100K a
year and my wife is a stay-at-home mom
the nature of my job requires me to be
on call and close to work leaving me
little choice but to pay a premium rent
of 2 000 per month we are currently
watching the housing market and still
learning the area and are socking money
away to buy a home I have 45 000 in the
bank doing nothing for me but I've been
hesitant to invest as we would like to
have the money available should a home
come up that we can buy I've been told
that cash and Savings in a savings
account is like melting ice what do I do
with it hmm well in this situation you
know when it comes to saving uh for a
house it's a little bit different than
just you know any other money that
you're putting aside you know typically
we wouldn't invest uh the money that
you're saving for a house unless you
know the timeline is you know five years
or more although Dave I've heard you say
that a lot of times you'll just pop some
money in an index fund and let it sit
there and grow if you you know know what
you might use it for I particularly
don't have this stomach for that I'd
probably put it in the hysa and just get
the best return on it that I possibly
could for the time being because it
sounds like you're kind of in that
moment where if the right thing comes
open you're ready to jump on it so yeah
I would keep it out of the market and I
would put it in a high yield savings
account maybe put it you know I've heard
Dave say that he'll put it in a CD that
sort of thing yeah high yield savings
account like you said it's perfect
um it's not melting ice
when you are getting ready to use the
money
and you're getting ready to use this
money and so if you were going to leave
it in a stupid savings account for 10
years then yeah it is melting ice yeah
but that's not your description you're
in the housing market you're ready to
buy and get rid of this premium rent and
everything else so yeah you definitely
go that route it's you're not doing the
wrong thing no Jade I did have a young
guy come in uh all the work I've done
over the years with different NFL and
and other professional athletes
um they just happen to be listening to
the show and say hey would you look at
my stuff yeah look at your stuff so it's
always interesting stories and of course
we've run into all the negative stories
where they've burned through all the
money you know I made 100 million
dollars I got nothing to show for it or
whatever that kind of stuff I've met
those guys and there's always a lot of
Shame and stuff on those guys but in the
in the in the light of what really is
saying
this guy comes in he's young I mean he's
like 20. oh well 28 years old maybe 26
years old he's been he been the league a
few years but not you know he wasn't an
old guy in the league by any stretch and
his sweet little wife and they drive in
a used van
wow and they come in and they go like
Dave you're going to kill us we've
messed up and I'm thinking they're going
to tell me they've blown all their money
and he goes I I you're just gonna be so
mad at me and I'm like I'm number one
I'm not gonna be mad at you regardless
of how dumb you are but what did you do
I mean did you do something dumb he goes
yeah we've got all our money in savings
count
and I said uh how much money do you have
in savings account uh 36 million oh whoa
and I'm like no I am not going to yell
at you I'm going to hug you because you
did everything right but one tiny thing
you actually you're a pro athlete who
has money you know what this is a
unicorn I mean you're incredible way to
go you're amazing I'm so proud of you
you actually lived on less than you make
you're driving a used car you're not
trying to impress your Posse you know
you're you're out you didn't buy your
mother a house you couldn't afford to
buy all the stupid butt stuff I usually
run into you have 36 million dollars and
the only thing you did wrong was you
didn't invest it no you you get a hug I
don't know you know so but yeah in his
case he is melting ice for sure he does
need to get that money invested so he
was wrong but not only yet get yelled at
wrong side though the smart side way to
go man I mean wow absolute stud
absolutely so proud of him all right
Keisha Is With Us in Atlanta Georgia hi
Keisha welcome to the Ramsay show
Hi how are you doing better than we
deserve what's up in your world
hi I was calling because I was looking
for some advice I am a retired veteran
collecting disability so I have the
arrogance that I have money to till I
die so I I do save money
however I don't have any IRAs because of
what I just mentioned what is the best
way for me to try to put money to save
money where I'm benefiting and not
losing like the previous caller the
caller today I have money sitting not
gaining a lot of interest how much money
do you have in savings
now I have 50 50 000.
good for you how old are you
I just turned 50 last year okay are you
working
no unfortunately the job market might
transition from the military was
extremely difficult
so I'm not working
okay so you're getting a substantial
disability you're saying from the
government right yes on my retirement I
mean I live within my means so I wasn't
questioning
what's the nature of your disability how
extreme
mental
how extreme Mental Health
yes
so it keeps you from working in a
traditional work environment is it
something that would keep you from
working in a non-traditional work
environment maybe working doing some
work from home
I can it keeps me from working from a
traditional and I could work from home
yes okay
so like uh PTSD type symptoms is that
what we're dealing with
yes okay that's great hey thank you for
your service Keisha thank you I'm sorry
yeah I'm sorry you ended up struggling
with this as a result of serving your
country
um
so and I'm glad that we have good
retirement and good disability in place
to take care of you that's a good thing
we the people should do that and so this
is a good story
because you're a good lady now if I woke
up in your shoes what would I do well
I've never struggled with PTSD I've
never been in a traumatic situation like
that that would affect me ongoing so I
can't really get into your shoes
honestly but uh in general or I to face
some kind of a disability I would find
something I could do in spite of or with
as a workaround that disability so in
your case as Jade was saying a
non-traditional thing maybe some kind of
almost self-employed thing where you
control the hours you control the stress
level you control the volume of work
that you do I would want to put my hand
to something because I think it's good
for our uh it's good for us there's
dignity and work you know what I'm
saying
yes I'm not saying you're lazy that you
did not hear me say that
but I am saying if I were you what yeah
how do you it's got to be designed just
for Keisha yeah whatever it is it's got
to be designed just for you
and that's why it might be a
self-employed thing it might be that you
you know you go take some uh coding
classes and learn to code and you simply
do contract work from home and you code
do coding where you don't have to deal
with humans much and you just I don't
know what it is I'm making stuff up
right now but all of that to say I'd
probably add something to that now
having said that you can live on your
retirement and your disability you don't
need the fifty thousand we would label
part of the 50 000 year emergency fund
and we would begin to invest the rest
one of the good things about creating an
income is in order to do Roth IRAs you
have to have an earned income retirement
and disability or not earned income by
the irs's definition for purposes of a
Roth IRA so if we can get you making a
little bit of money then you could do a
Roth with some of this money and that's
what I would start talking about
investment in the loss yeah but you
again you'd have to create some income
that's not retirement or disability
doesn't have to be mine
so in the meanwhile I say something I
have 75 of my income available that I
could be saving yeah what's the best
thing to do with that money
I would get in touch with one of our
smartvester pros and simply start doing
some investing in mutual funds it's just
not going to be in a retirement account
and what you're looking for what's
called Low turnover write that down and
ask the smartvestor pro about it click
smartmister pro at ramsesolutions.com
and you want to ask them about a low
turnover mutual fund that's a low taxed
environment type mutual fund when you're
not inside of a retirement account
that's good to look at
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever to
bring things back by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
foreign
Warsaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt freeze stage Isaac and
Brenna are with us hey guys welcome
thank you Dave where do you guys live
Fairmont Minnesota Fairmont Minnesota
now where is what's that near anything I
would know Rochester Mankato okay cool
well welcome to Nashville bit of a haul
down here sir good to have you and here
to do a debt free scream how much did
you pay off 114
000 wow how long did that take uh just
under a year good for you and your range
of income during that time
um
well our income was 150 000 for the year
okay cool what do y'all do for a living
I am a small business owner
um what kind of business should we got
masonry construction oh good great and
in the cold oh my gosh yes wow what
about you Brenna I was working as a
project manager and a copywriter for a
medical device manufacturing company at
the time okay and now you are now I'm a
stay-at-home mom all right ding ding
good goals okay what kind of debt was
the 114 000. well I had some remaining
student loans and uh I had a car loan as
well as uh the loan I took out to become
a business owner okay so you're fairly
normal yes fairly normal and uh
something happened a year ago what got
you on this Ramsay stuff uh well the the
little girl for me that we have right
out here
um I just couldn't imagine having
a hundred and fourteen thousand dollars
in debt uh when we knew our goal was for
her to be a stay-at-home mom and so uh
it was a roadblock yeah I couldn't
handle that stress yeah so for context
the monthly payment on our loans was
more than three times our current
mortgage so wow it was a lot and we knew
we couldn't have live on just one income
with paying that off so so how long have
you been married
We Got Married the fall of 2020 so oh
yeah why not why not I mean you know
yeah it's a pandemic wedding oh yes and
uh good for you all right so how did you
get connected to this Ramsey stuff
well
um I actually was listening to you when
I was probably 23
um just a casual listener so it was like
uh Dave Ramsey he's he's all right you
know but I wasn't following any of your
programs at that time so
uh I liked finances and I liked you know
being wise with my money but debt was
okay for me at that time
and then we got married and he would
come home from work every day and tell
me all these crazy stories that he heard
on the Ramsay show and so I started
listening to the podcast and
um just for entertainment at first but
then I caught on and actually when we
first got married we were seeing a
financial advisor who's not affiliated
with you but he told us to take the
majority of our savings and to pay off
our car loan and the remainder of my
student loans and he told us just do it
he said you'll you won't regret it in 20
years from now you'll thank me and so we
did that initially and then later that
year of our marriage we bought a dog
bought a house and kind of got a little
off track and we still had the business
loan mm-hmm
um and then shortly after we bought our
house we were planning a bunch of
Renovations
um not following the Dave Ramsey plan at
all and
um a few months after we bought the
house we were out had just gone on a
shopping spree and spent about 300 and
we were out to eat at a nice steakhouse
and I looked at Isaac and I told him
that I was sick of spending money and
that I felt out of control with our
finances and I told him that I keep on
listening to the debt-free screams on
your show and I just have this nagging
feeling that if we can do this if we can
pay off our debt why wouldn't we and he
agreed and so right there in that
restaurant we went through our finances
and decided how long it would take us
and decided that we were going to do it
and that was the last time we ate out at
a restaurant for ah a year I love it I
love it you know no more shopping sprees
or we we paused Renovations on our home
and
um didn't go on any trips or anything
and just went hardcore at it so I love
it so way to go gosh it took you a year
to do this for the people listening what
was the key to getting through like what
was what was the one thing that you
would recommend to anybody listening
um I I think we just had a vision you
know a vision for what we wanted our
lives to look like in
5 10 20 40 years
and
um
looking at your plan we just knew that
was the way
and
I think there's a lot of moments in life
where you realize
when
you're what way you need to take you
know I've had those moments and this is
just one of those turning points yeah
that steak dinner was valuable yes it
was at least what happened at the steak
dinner was valuable so you guys are
impressive yeah way to go you guys I'm
proud of you good work who was cheering
you on outside the two of you well my
parents both of our parents were
definitely big cheerleaders in our
journey and yeah and I'd say for me
um cheerleader was we had a little girl
and well my wife was pregnant and so I
you know I look at her and I'm like oh
like this is the reason yeah I know
that's just my why yeah it's my wife you
got a big enough why you can do anything
right that's right yeah yeah good for
you guys well done and your little
girl's name is Beverly all right are we
gonna bring her into the debt-free
scream yeah all right bring her over how
old is she she is 10 months old all
right that's perfect oh how cute she is
hey we've got the live and give bundle
for you that includes uh The Total Money
Makeover book and the baby steps
millionaire book both of those are
number one best sellers you can read
them or give them away or both and a
membership to Financial Peace University
if you haven't been through it go
through it if you have then give it to
somebody this is the live and give
bundle it's all for you guys thanks for
making the trip all the way down here
congratulations we're very proud of you
thank you thank you how's it feel to be
free it feels wonderful never go back in
debt never not for anything not for
anything how much do you have left on
your house 129
000. no you're not far on that you'll
get there pretty quick making a hundred
and a half with no payments four years
it's it's done four years with the plan
that's about right I like it and you
guys are how old I am 31. I'm 26. all
right look at you man you guys are
amazing congratulations it's exciting
guys Isaac and Brenna and Beverly 114
000 paid off in one year making 150
everything changes when you get a big
enough why count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one we're
debt free
that is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen that's how it's done oh man
good job you guys hey uh a lot of the
debt free screamers you hear me giving
them Financial Peace University to give
away a lot of them have already been
through it
Not Unusual at all and lots of your
start of the Year fired up to make
changes with your money but now that
some time has gone by
It's Cold Outside the Fire starts to go
out change is hard transformation is
hard
and when you're dealing with money
you're dealing with a person in the
mirror which is really really hard and
that's why you got to have people
walking with you and that's why
Financial Peace University has been a
game changer for gosh almost 10 million
people now in a Financial Peace
University class you're going to learn
our proven plan to get out of debt and
build wealth and you'll do it with other
people going after the same goals you
are you do not have to figure this out
alone
there's hundreds of FPU classes going on
all across the country online and in
person get in a class right now it's
nine lessons nine weeks you'll be
through the thing you're going to be
reset and recalibrated and ready to go
so join right now to find an FPU class
go to ramseysolutions.com class all one
word no spaces ramseysolutions.com
FPU class FPU class and Jade you're
teaching one I am I have an FPU that is
starting March 1st and you can sign up
by going uh to the FPU page or I'm sure
that uh James will go ahead and put that
QR on the co the QR code on the screen
if you're watching the YouTube show and
you can sign up there man we're trying
to pack it out Dave I want to teach
these people what helped Sam and I
change our lives over five years ago so
yeah almost a half a million dollars
that she and Sam paid off after she
knows what she's doing and uh that also
means that she's not going to take your
little whiny excuses I'm sure not she's
going to love you enough to pop you
upside the head and get you going maybe
maybe not quite that hard that would be
not not the ladies that's it that's just
the guys
check it out this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us America Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Alex is with
us in Fort Worth Texas hi Alex how are
you
doing all right Dave how are you guys
doing better than we deserve how can we
help
well Dave I got a little love note from
my mortgage company uh with our annual
escrow uh account disclosure
apparently we had a shortage on our
escrow account usually it's a couple
hundred bucks a year like it's usually
fairly close to the actual and projected
amounts but this year it's like a
difference of over four thousand dollars
and
um did your taxes or your insurance go
up
Insurance taxes it was short by like 150
bucks which I I totally get but
um
the insurance though just absolutely
floored us and they're saying our
mortgage is going to go up about 600
bucks and your homeowner's insurance
went up four thousand dollars in one
year
yeah and that's that's what we're really
lost on because I I called my neighbor
who has the exact same floor plan as us
different insurance provider did you
shop the homeowners insurance and change
it
yeah that's what we're that's what we're
definitely doing right now I'm talking
to like four different companies right
now but
uh it's clear that we're not gonna keep
this company uh
but at the same time we're trying to
figure out what do we do in the meantime
it's like we could we could dip into the
emergency fund and pay off that shortage
just to kind of get rid of it no it's
not a shortage if you change the policy
okay
have they already paid the premium the
four thousand dollar extra premium
um
I think they've paid part of it I think
they're wanting us to make up the rest
um
yeah I'm not sure but um to be honest
when it comes to Escrow escrow is one of
those things that I usually lost on it
typically is in arrears
and so what that means is in reverse and
so they're billing you now for what
they've already paid because when you
for they're building you now for last
year
because when you set up when you got the
loan you set up an escrow account as
part of your closing costs and you paid
out that you you went ahead and paid out
so it may be what I would want to do is
I want to get on the phone with them and
get through exactly what has been paid
because I'm going to cancel this policy
and get a reasonably priced policy
and then that's going to change your
escrow back
close
and you'll just change it and then they
just need to do an audit and set it up
they they only they don't need to
withhold you know four or five six
hundred dollars a month if they only
need a hundred dollars a month in which
case you would permanently change your
payment by enough to cover your taxes
and insurance
but you need to get the right payment on
the books the right health insurance
plan or life I'm sorry homeowners
insurance plan on the books first and
then you've got to pay for whatever you
paid but if you cancel that homeowner's
insurance in the middle of the year
you're only going to have paid for it
for half of the year not for the whole
year
so what I'm saying is I want to get into
it now and cancel it as soon as possible
so that I don't and if they haven't
already paid for it for a whole year at
four thousand dollar increase then
you're only going to have like a one
thousand dollar increase because you're
canceling it
right okay
all right
um yeah because we we were just looking
at them and we're like there's there's
no way we're gonna stay uh no I'm just
yeah it's no yeah they're they're uh so
what you need to do is go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on uh
insurance for PNC it's Property and
Casualty and get with one of our
insurance elps they're Independent
Insurance Brokers
and that means they'll shop around among
several different companies and get you
and your particular situation the best
deal and usually you bundle it with your
cars too and you can re and the typical
person shopping against some of these
other companies uh they'll save 800
bucks in your case you may say four
thousand dollars
that would be great yeah and then so
what you're going to do and then you're
going to take that new policy and then
get with the mortgage company and find
out how much of the old policy has
actually been paid or earned and you've
got to pay the portion that's actually
been used so if that policy with that
four thousand dollar increase has been
on the books for three months then it's
only going to be you know one-fourth of
four thousand dollar increase you follow
me
right and so but if it's been on the
books a whole year then you bid it for a
year but I don't I don't think it has I
think you're catching it because they
come after you pretty quick with an
escrow increase if they're on their game
and it sounds like they are so yeah get
the policy changed get it shopped get
with them request an audit and then
write one check into a true up and then
set your new based on your current new
homeowners insurance and taxes 150 more
on the taxes more on the homeowners but
not four thousand more now what should
my payment be reset the payment to be
the accurate amount it is going to go up
but it's not going to go up as much as
it they came at you with because they
were assuming you're stupid enough to
keep that old policy escrow escrow
accounts almost all have errors in them
yep ongoing you constantly have to stay
on top of it they almost all have errors
and when they discover an error that
they're behind on they always almost
double dip and hit you so he needed
sound like they needed about a four
hundred dollar raise and they were
giving them a 600 residence payment
yeah I don't like dealing with escrow
well it's just it's it's you're dealing
with bureaucrats on the other end of the
phone that's another problem too Tom's
in Salt Lake City hey Tom how are you
I'm doing great how are you Dave better
than we deserve what's up
so uh long story short uh my wife and I
have uh were debt free our house and
everything uh since 2000 since 21. way
to go and uh thank you uh yeah it was a
big help with your system that worked
out great uh we so we're currently now
uh investing heavily the kids are in our
retirement caught up uh we're also
saving for what we would like to do for
our our
our forever home uh so we want to buy a
law that we like and then build a house
that we you know to be designed to put
on that uh our question is so we there a
lot came up that um we looked at we were
really really loving it it looked like
it could have been perfect
um but we let it go because financially
we're not we don't have the savings to
just cash cash flow and stay out of debt
good
um so so we we held off we let it go
um
and it was so good about it but at the
same time we feel like maybe maybe we
missed out and we wanted to get your
opinions for so all that is horrible and
I agree with completely if at all
possible ever uh mortgages are the I
feel like can be a gray area of debt and
so in with what would you recommend
should we just keep on the track and
just if it takes us five years or ten
years to save up to get this lot that we
want and just keep passing on Lots as
they come along and stop stop looking or
would you if a perfect lot came along
should we take what we've saved put that
as a down payment get a new mortgage and
keep the house as a rental that'd be the
eventual
uh what we'd really like to do the best
is keep the house we have now paid off
as a rental and then move up to our home
and have a mortgage on your home
right well no the the idea would be to
save up before we move and not have any
mortgage ever again oh and then in the
old houses are paid for rental and your
new house was paid for
right so why couldn't you save up the
lot price then if you can save up the
whole thing
it's going to be there's no such thing
okay
where we would like to be right now it's
a nice move up house I'll go with that
and you're going to pay cash for it so
why can't you pay cash for the lot
well we don't have it yet I know it's
still four four five years out I know
and if you can't pay cash for the house
either
no need to buy the lot until we're ready
to pay cash for the lot if you can't
even pay cash for the lot you're nowhere
near paying cash for the house so what's
the hurry our plan was to pay for the
lot and then start with because we would
like to have some really nice uh
Landscaping trees and whatnot something
we missed with where we're at now we
have almost no trees so our thought was
find a place we like buy a lot it's not
like in a subdivision we're kind of
looking up in in the hills and the
mountainsides
um you're missing the point
you told me you were going to pay cash
for this house that you're moving into
if you're going to pay cash for the
house that you're moving into you gotta
at least have the money to pay cash for
the lot first
so I don't see really what the trip is
except you're got house fever and a lot
fever because you're out there riding
around every weekend looking at stuff
chill till you got the money that's what
I would do this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money Natasha is in
Atlanta hi Natasha how are you
hi good and you guys better than we
deserve what's up in your world
me and my husband being very good
managing money I believe we both make
good money my husband works in the film
industry and we end up moving to Atlanta
so you have like a stable job here in
income
and I am a teacher so we make around
eighty thousand dollars and sometimes it
could be all the way to a hundred
dollars yearly
but it has been a roller coaster for us
to be on the same page and finally we
found your program and we're trying to
make the right choices
this next two months we're gonna be like
negative zero we're just gonna pay all
our you know regular utilities and our
payments are pretty high so we're trying
to figure it out right now if we have to
get rid of one of our cars even though
our cars don't pay as much we have one
car is 560 a month the other is per 100
a month uh monthly
but we just don't know where to start
right now we're I'm gonna do like a
garage sale to make the thousand dollars
to start for our savings we have zero
savings
we're just a mess and we need to know
how can we start something are you guys
doing a budget
well that's the first thing we started
um but right now the budget is idealing
but we have so much things that are like
overdue payments that
you know if we're not gonna even have
enough money for the bot yet we're gonna
have to catch up the next two months
just doing payments and just doing
payment well I think that you're a
little bit confused about how the budget
is working so what you're going to do so
what do you bring home every month
around four thousand dollars
um I bring
2800 and my husband brings six thousand
oh six thousand oh okay great so you're
going to plug that into your budget uh
what how do you do your budget now is it
a spreadsheet what are you using to
create your budget every month
I just have a it's not really a
spreadsheet it's just you know a chart
that I created and it's we have eight
thousand dollars for a hundred dollars
that's income okay eight thousand four
hundred and or our goal is eight
thousand eight um 180. okay well let's
start with what your outgo actually is
so you're gonna start with the 8400 and
you're just gonna go down the line and
you're gonna spend all of that money so
you're gonna start with your expenses
and go through making sure that you're
making minimum payments on everything
not just your you know the expenses that
you do every month like groceries and
things like that but also your debt
and just to keep everything current I
know that you said that you're behind on
some stuff but start out by making
minimum payments
and once you've done that I think you're
going to find that there are things that
you're spending money on that you don't
actually need to spend money on because
you guys have a great income what kind
of uh what kind of debt do you have on
well we have the two car loans and car
number one that you owe 400 a month on
what's the balance on it
on this 160 what's the balance on it
no that was a
405.60 so one the 560 is 25
000 and the 400 is 12 000. okay all
right and what are your other debts
the student loans how much around twenty
thousand dollars
okay what else
we also have um medical bills and there
are already affected our credit scores
and how much I don't I don't know the
number for that I think it's a roughly
around fifteen thousand dollars and
you're paying monthly on these
we're not okay so you're not paying
anything on it you're not paying
anything on that at all okay what else
um well
that's it like what's your house
we paid we don't own we rent what's your
rent
2000 a month 2 000 a month okay yeah all
right what are you behind on
right now we're on three months of the
car and we also laid one month on rent
okay so what that tells me is is that
you all are out of control on your
spending
because you have enough to pay these
bills I don't even know where you're
getting to 8 400 I can't get there
you're not paying anything on these
medical you got 2 000 plus you got food
lights and water and then you got a
thousand sixty and or no you got 916
credit card debt or in car payments
student loans on hold with Biden
yeah you're not paying anything on it
you're not working a budget I think
you're just guessing at the numbers
every month
and if you're not on a budget you guys
are spending like crazy and then you're
not prioritizing the things
this is what has been happening like I
tried to for us to speak upon about you
who's the spender you or him
why does this say on my screen you're
considering a divorce
yeah why does it say on my screen you're
you haven't brought that up in our
conversation
Escape that I feel I have from the
situation
oh you know oh that would be if it's his
fault but you didn't just now say it was
his fault you said it was both your
fault
but it's hard to for both of us to be on
the same page it's just hard like for
now I I explain him that we need to like
close our personal accounts and one of
the things that you guys recommend is
for both to have one account together
and he's like okay we can open one
account but we will still keep temporary
Accounts at the same time I feel he
doesn't trust separate accounts aren't
your problem
your problem as you spin like you're in
Congress
somewhere between the two of you
I'm sorry what do you say last I said
you spend out of control no number of
accounts will stop that
having a singular account is not going
to fix that getting rid of him is not
going to fix it if you're the problem
so what we've got to do is you guys are
going to have to lay out a game plan
that the two of you agree to and you
guys are getting ready to head into
bankruptcy because you're going to get
evicted and repoed you're not but one
car payment of boy from getting into
repo land and you're about half a
mortgage or half a rent payment from
being evicted if you're my tenant
because I don't fool around people not
paying their rent
so you guys got to get this stuff
together so here's what I'm going to do
I'm going to put you on hold and we're
going to hook you up with one of our
coaches and they're going to sit down
with the two of you free
and I'm gonna pay for you to go through
Financial Peace University and hopefully
that'll save your marriage
but the two of you it's time for y'all
to look in the mirror and go enough
because you don't the numbers you gave
us honey you got to sell these cars
they're both ridiculous number one but
number two you actually can pay these
payments with the income you've got it's
doable but you didn't even choose to pay
your rent instead you chose to go party
somewhere I don't know where your
freaking money's going hold on we'll
help you
[Music]
foreign
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America Jade
warshaw Ramsey personalities my co-host
well taxes
suck
taxes
are confusing
make me angry
but grown-ups have to deal with them
anyway so confusing angry suck yeah all
these things are true so you got to get
some help with this if you got a
complicated return and don't trust just
anybody with your taxes
you need a real tax expert with
you know that that didn't just start
doing this two weeks ago okay which
means they barely if maybe don't know
more than you know which is nothing
hey that's kind of me I know a little
bit about taxes about Karen dadgum to
you my stuff is so complicated I don't
do it I can promise you freaking size of
a phone book when I'm done with it it's
ridiculous and Float a small country
with a crap you know so you got to get
somebody in your corner if you've got a
complicated return go to Ramsey
solutions.com taxpro you can get one of
the Ramsey trusted tax pros and we'll
connect you to them doesn't cost
anything to connect you and then you
interview them and figure out if you
feel like they got their act together we
interviewed them and we think they got
their act together otherwise they
wouldn't be Ramsay trusted thus the name
so check it out get some help in your
corner ramseysolutions.com taxpro all
right Jade uh our last caller uh we
didn't have time to do a full counseling
session for Co for money on the air let
me help you guys if you're out there
facing that because I feel like we
didn't address the key issue that would
be a great learning for everyone else
if you are behind
on your payments
behind on your bills how do you do a
budget
okay well the first thing you do is you
have to Force rank
prioritize
you have to prioritize your dollars and
that means we're going to take care of
what we used to learn and they no longer
teach it in the eighth grade called
Civics the difference in necessities and
luxuries
98 of what everybody spends money on in
America is a freaking luxury
so let me help you with what an actual
necessity is
food
there's one no eating out is not a
necessity
some of you people all you know how to
make is reservations and you got to work
on that okay so food at home cheap that
you bought at the grocery store with a
coupon food is a necessity
utilities lights and water so you have
heat
and cool utilities is number two cable
is not a utility cable is not a utility
thank you Hulu is not on your list oh
Netflix is not a necessity Tiger King
let me help you okay I just had to put
that out there just helping you with
your little increase there to 12.95
uh okay all right got it all but I'm not
broke okay so I got Hulu and Netflix so
I'll just give them a little ad there
but they're not a necessity you can live
without them
promise you now once you've gotten food
and utilities where belly's full and
we're warm
number three is shelter
so you take care of your place to live
so you're not homeless you pay your rent
now almost everyone can scratch around
and make enough money to buy their food
keep their electricity current if
they're first
second and third and keep your rent paid
right the only way you get behind on
rent which our last caller was is if you
are completely discombobulated screwed
up and you're spending crazy money on
something else
you'd have to be it's the only way
because otherwise you go okay I'm gonna
go out to eat but I'm gonna get evicted
that's called
insanity
I mean stupid right yeah you know we're
going on this trip but we're gonna get
evicted well you that that's I mean what
are your parents cousins really I mean
seriously no one does that but people do
it all the time because when we get all
stressed out we don't Force rank
priorities and if you'll just get real
calm cool and collected and go we're
gonna eat before we do anything
not eat out we're going to pay the
utilities not cable before we do
anything we're going to pay rent and
when you do those three things you got a
lot of money most of you left over after
those three things then the next one's
Transportation yeah now that this is the
one that gets people Dave no well they
had 960 dollars in car payments they did
so we're going to fix their
transportation problem because we're
going to sell that crap tomorrow okay if
you can't pay the car payment hello
there's a signal here God is saying sell
the car
it wasn't even Dave God said it and you
know how I know he said that the
blessings of the Lord have no sorrow
added to them that's right he said that
in the Psalms and if you have sorrow
added to something it's not from God
and this lady has sorrow they're about
to have their cars repoed and she's
thinking about divorce and she's
thinking about divorce because they're
going to pay their car payments so these
cars need to go in the meantime
you actually have eight thousand dollars
a month coming in
how almost 9 000 a month coming in how
do you not pay one thousand dollars
worth a car and two thousand dollars
worth of rent that's only three thousand
dollars five thousand dollars left over
after that how are you behind on those
because you didn't have them prioritized
that's what it tells me right okay after
30 years of doing this I have great
insight
[Laughter]
these are things that you need to build
into your your daily way of life your
budget is something that is not
something that you make once a year and
you come back to it when things are bad
you do your budget every single month
before the month begins you create that
plan you spend every dollar on paper or
digital paper every month before it
begins so you have a plan so you can see
what are the areas that need attention
maybe you do need to get your income up
that's not really the case in her
situation it wouldn't hurt she's got a
spin they've got a spending problem and
maybe you'll start to see that as you
put your budget together but let's just
pretend for a second okay she said she's
three car payments or two car payments
yeah okay so what's it take to get
current and pay this month two thousand
dollars she could do that this month and
what's it take issues are one month
behind on rent yeah what's it take to
get current on that another 2 000 yeah
it's four thousand bucks yeah so you
could be 100 current on the things that
matter in one month that's right and
herself anything else you're not gonna
do anything else something else might
get behind what and if something like if
you got MasterCard laying there they can
jump in a creek we get we we don't get
evicted
and we don't pay MasterCard if we got to
choose when you like the taste of steak
at a restaurant more than you like the
feeling of paying your bills on time you
got a problem hello
you would rather sit whine and dine
yourself you would rather go on trips
that you can't afford than just have the
Peace of paying your your bills on time
and sleeping at night yeah but here's
the thing if you're behind like that you
said it early in the conversation how do
you you're doing the budget wrong what
you need to do is you need to spend this
month's eight thousand six hundred
dollars on this month's problems and
until you clear food utilities housing
and transportation and get them all
current you don't spend anything else on
anything I don't care if somebody
doesn't like it oh and you stop your
stupid 401K withholding you're over here
making Investments while you're paying a
thousand dollars in car payments okay so
that this is what's going on in that
house yeah and not fussing at her I'm
just saying mathematically this is so
easy for some of you to turn around
within one month or two months you could
be a hundred percent current and on the
things that matter yeah because here's
the thing you emotionally
Dr John deloney could do a whole clinic
on this you're emotionally completely
shut down in crisis mode trauma mode
your brain your fit your critical
thinking skills shut down when you are
in threat of being hungry homeless and
have your lights cut off and your car's
repoed
these are the necessities of life yeah
to have you know food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities clothing we
don't need to worry about you know you
got clothing okay shut up there's 73
pairs of shoes in there shut up you
don't need clothing
good Lord the money we spent I mean
we've got enough clothing last okay yeah
so um I mean if you're trying to make a
fashion statement you're getting evicted
you've got other issues right well you
got to grow up Dave and I can say I can
say that because I've been there I've
had to look in the mirror and go Jade
you're acting like a child you're buying
clothes you're going out to eat and you
cannot pay your bills you've got to
change you've got to do what you're
doing differently doing things the same
way and expecting the same result that's
Insanity so and I was an insane child
take care of the four walls first that's
not Insanity it's the opposite food
shelter clothing transportation and
utilities get current on them before you
worry about anything else everyone else
can jump on the creek until that's gone
yep
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions
on the debt free stage Gilbert and
Michelle are with us hey guys welcome
hey good to have you where do you guys
live Tucson Arizona owned great place
well welcome to Nashville good to have
you all the way up here to do a debt
free scream how much have you paid off
a hundred and thirteen thousand four
hundred and Seventeen dollars way to go
and how long did this take you 39 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time uh we always hover
around
165 117 between there okay cool what do
y'all do for a living so I'm in sales
and then I also have a part-time
counseling job on this item a 1099
through a Psychiatry office great and I
do it Consulting in Tucson great very
cool what kind of debt was your 113 400.
it was our house
whoa looking at weird people I love it
way to go you weirdos what's this house
worth what's it worth I think around 300
now we're not quite nice yeah and it's
paid for yeah I love it man how old are
you two I'm 43. I'm 44. and you're a
paid four house the paid for a house
that's so weird yeah it's awesome it
really settle in on you how unusual you
are seriously
very few 44 year olds have a paid for a
house
every day kind of settles in a little
bit more like when I open up the door to
do laundry it's all of a sudden like oh
my gosh I my we own our house nobody can
take this from us man that's so cool
yeah I see it build because we took a
yardstick and numbered it so that way we
could track it and every night when we
ate dinner together we could see where
that was at and it was there every night
it's showing where we were at and also
where we were going sometimes that felt
like forever yeah and other times where
we put large amounts we're like whoa
look how far that just went and so you
could really see it with the yardstick
that we had a little bit like parenting
the days are sure the days are long and
the years are short yeah
that's a good analogy
so were you with us before the home
payoff journey in the debt-free journey
as well yeah so uh when I first met
Gilbert I was in grad school racking up
student loans and I had a car loan and
he was 100 debt free I was paid for and
even in that time he actually bought
another property cash and so he was kind
of my first like how does this happen
and I did think at that time like this
well he can do it but I don't know how
I'm gonna do it and then I graduated and
I knew I'd take a pay cut but as I was
getting job offers at counseling therapy
offices and everything I looked at the
numbers I'm like I can't eat I have all
this student loan and now I can't eat
and I sat we were doing numbers at the
tables and I sat there and I cried and I
cried and so that's when I started
realizing I I'll pay off my car loan
that will be the very first thing and it
gave me my first like win as you say and
then after that I was like What if I
didn't have my school alone what would
that feel like and I remember I had a
classmate she had this like little
strange envelope system and I kind of
started Googling like how to get out of
debt and of course you came up and from
that moment on it was definitely a
spiritual thing because I sat on my
couch and I read it and I was like why
not why can't I do it and then from that
moment on I just went for it and I think
it was 24 months almost to the exact day
of paying off a little over eighty
thousand dollars
how long have you all been married
March will be four years okay so after
you get married then we look at the
house the house again there's some 39
months ding ding yeah so we knew we
wanted to pay it off fast and we were
kind of building a plan and
um getting a little bit aggressive and
then 2020 we're like okay we're gonna
really go at it and then obviously the
pandemic happens and I get furloughed
for uh almost three months from there
and of course at that time you're like I
don't know if I'm gonna have a job when
I go back I mean we wrote that out
really nicely because we were out of
debt but we thought what if this house
wasn't here how much better would that
be and from that moment on I went back
to work and we just went gung-ho from
there we stayed gazelle intense I know
that's not necessarily the plan to have
to but we wanted to stay that just
because we knew how much Freedom that
would give us amen yeah so the last 12
months is I think we paid off around 75
000 oh most of it most of it was in the
last yeah yeah we sold but you can see
the Finish Line it's weird you just you
get geared up yeah yeah we ended up
selling one of his stocks and then we
had a little bit over in our savings and
then we took my car fund I think it was
like the last month we're like let's
just do it let's get rid of it so who
supported you in this process or who
thought you were crazy well it's either
one of the two
well Gilbert was definitely my biggest
fan I guess you could say throughout the
process and he really supported me and
um friends and family were there they're
like okay cool that's great you know I
even had some friends like good for you
but that's just not for me but they
don't have a paid off house no no no no
yeah way to go you guys so yeah we met
later on in in our life for us and so I
my story a little bit for my journey
happened well before then in my early
20s and part of my story was a little
bit similar to yours Dave where I had
lots of real estate but I kind of went
about it in the wrong away with large
amounts of debt and then an 08 happened
in 09 happened and I was able to get out
from some of that but I'm not all of it
but it was just enough to still bury me
in that but I learned so much that and I
was from that on I was never again yeah
and so I rebuilt from the ground up but
from then on I paid cash for my house
and it was a small house I went from a
nice custom home what was it's called
the over Valley area next to Tucson I
got rid of that and I went to a little
two-bedroom townhouse just because I'm
like I'm I'm never going back to debt
and so even though it was my primary
home and I was affording it I knew if I
just sold that and I started from
scratch from then on it was just going
to set me in a good spot and I did that
and I was able to build some wealth
in some of that time on my own before we
had met and some of that and so it was a
spot when we met you know
you hear some people of like well on the
relationship side would you take on
someone and meet someone in debt in any
of that but I knew who she was as a
person she was working it yeah she was
who she was as a person and she was
someone worth going through that
experience with even though I had gotten
out of it and we weren't married yet
yeah I didn't partake in that and it was
her win she ended up winning herself and
go fighting through that to get out of
her student loan debts amen well done
with the houses paid off now I think
that that did throw us into the baby
steps millionaires from there yeah
I love to hear it not only do you have a
paid for house at 44 but your baby steps
millionaires yeah I love it I love it
Wow way to go y'all thank you how's it
feel to be free
oh sometimes words can't even say it
yeah one of the things that was just
before we're still working and we saw
like what was happening with student
loans and a bunch of them were getting
forgiven there was frustration at the
table one night from that like we worked
so hard for that and it's just gonna get
rid off but it was like but what who it
made us
like you can't just give you be given
that you have to work through that and
become that yeah and that changed our
perspective on that then no amount of
money can actually build those
characters yeah it's who are you
becoming and so for me to live in a
country where there's freedom but to my
biblical basis it means for me to
so the data slave to the lender and once
I really put that principle in my life
I'm like I want to live a free life that
means I have to stay out of debt and I
encourage anyone else even if you're
just playing with that you feel like
you're just managing it because you make
a large amount of money
I hear a lot of people that make a lot
but they just manage it that is one of
the big differences between uh doing
stuff Ramsey and just doing Financial
stuff
because we're so into you and who you
are the relationships we're into the
character into that whole process as
much as we are here's the tactics for
getting out of debt uh that that what we
end up doing and it's almost
unintentional but it's also a necessary
part of the journey if it's going to be
permanent is we're not only leading you
to get out of debt we're helping you
transform yeah to become something
different yeah in the process that
happens so often in that process be not
conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
it's not it's not merely paying off debt
it's a complete metamorphosis a complete
transformation you guys are incredible
I'm so proud of you thank you we've got
the live and give bundle for you it's
The Total Money Makeover book The Baby
Steps millionaires book and the
Financial Peace University membership
way to go Gilbert and Michelle house and
everything 44 years old Tucson Arizona
113 000 paid off in third in 39 months
making 165 five count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream three three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
man that is awesome this is the Ramsay
shot
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Sam's with us in
Lansing Michigan hey Sam welcome to the
Ramsey Show
Hi how are you guys today great how can
we help
um my wife's uh informed me a couple
weeks ago that she was 23 24
000 in credit card debt without me
knowing over the course of the last year
and I was wondering what would be the
best way to pay it off we have a couple
options
um
I got lucky rather be lucky than good I
won 36 000 at the casino
um but that money I already
um about a month ago and I already had
that money tied up in Money Market
because I'm using that for the down
payment on my next home
um we could cash in her 401K which has
25 000 in it and pay it off
or do we just
um kind of suck it up and just make the
payments and just pay it down a month by
month
um I just wondering what the best option
would be to avoid the interest payments
and everything like that yeah
you realize the interest payments aren't
the real problem in your house right
uh how long have you been married how
long have you been married
we have been married for a year and a
half now okay
okay and how long has she had this debt
um a year it started
um basically when my son was born a
little bit over a year ago and it was
just uh online ordering
stuff like that three different credit
cards going shopping kind of thing and I
never really noticed that we have
separate finances and I never really
noticed it because we don't have any
debt you know other than our house
so how's that working for you
oh it was working fantastic up until a
couple weeks ago don't think it is do
you
no not been work it's not been working
for some time like ever in your married
life it just was your revealed it was
just revealed a couple weeks ago
correct yeah you all are not on the same
page
not at all also she's spending as a
coping mechanism
she she's there's something that she's
trying to cope with and she's not doing
it in a healthy way and so she's looking
to spending and so she's Revenge
spending because you're gambling
I don't gamble that I that was the
second time I had done at the casino in
five years
what'd you spend
and did you budget for it or did you
just go and do it on a whim
uh we just did we just did we just did
it at a limb basically
um
well all right so
I think the thing that number one when
we're meeting when we're researching
millionaires
one of the things we find
typically among and we've done the
largest study of millionaires ever done
Sam is that the husband and wife are
working together
and there aren't secrets and there is
not impulsive spending and uh the number
of millionaires in our study that became
millionaires in casinos is precisely
zero the number of millionaires in our
study whose wife or husband hides their
finances from them because they don't
have good communication is precisely
zero so those are the things that
concern me more than the actual credit
card debt do you see what I'm saying
yes I do so if you guys want to prosper
and do extremely well which is our goal
to help you because we love you we want
you to win uh it would entail combining
your finances only one checking account
and a budget meeting every month that
the two of you sit down together both of
you have a vote some reason she doesn't
think she's got a vote she had to hide
it from shame or guilt or something and
we've got to rebuild trust which has
been violated here
and uh the two of you together she has a
vote you have a vote we are in agreement
about what our future goals are and
where we're going from there
and so
um you don't agree with this but I'm
going to tell you what I think okay
because you called here
um I think you both did something stupid
and the only good news is it cancels out
I think you got lucky instead of losing
a pile of money you came home with a
pile of money that's the worst thing
that can happen at a casino because
you're so dumb then you go back again
thinking you're that guy and so I'm
cashing this money out paying off these
credit cards we're going to combine our
finances and we're going to set a goal
where we're very diligent very steady
not flashy to save up a down payment for
a home together and meantime whatever
spending we're going to do that is
reasonable spending the two of us are
going to be in agreement every single
month before the month begins and not
following through on that you or her is
lying to your spouse
and uh so what she did here is not cute
it's not funny and what you did here is
not cute and it's not funny it can be
devastating if it's extended out and
forward both of them can be and so I you
know I I'm fussing at you because I love
you and I want you to win but if you are
my kid and you're 30 years old this is
exactly how I would talk to you and what
I would tell you as your friend uh not
because I'm your dad but because I love
you and because I want you to win and so
uh
Sam if you haven't had in our world we
call what she did Financial infidelity
yeah because it activates the same place
in you the sexual infidelity does
because it's a violation of trust yeah
to run up 24
000 and destroy or rather delay your
dream of buying a home because of
financial misbehavior yeah and a lie
yeah and to be honest if I'm in their
situation I'm probably going to seek out
some counseling some marriage counseling
yeah because they're they're early on
and and this is not they're still
forming that that foundation and this is
not the sort of thing that you want in
the foundation you want to get to the
bottom of this find out why you guys are
keeping secrets find out why she's
feeling neces feeling it's necessary to
medicate by spending and and possibly
same for you Sam I and I think if I were
in your shoes when I was 24 and some guy
said to me what I just said to you I
would have a tendency to blow it off
like you're overreacting Dave you're
overstating this and what I'm saying is
is these two things uh these three
things not working together hiding and
lying about money and gambling are three
things that will cause you to not become
a millionaire so this is like a million
dollar discussion
that's why this is important so I'm not
overreacting because even though it's
only 24
000 and 36 000 it's small in the in the
scope of Life what the the behaviors are
going to prohibit you or delay you at
minimum from becoming wealthy to the
tune of millions and millions of dollars
so this is a this is a I'm not
overreacting because this is millions of
dollars we're talking about absolutely
over time yeah Dave you're being kind
because this this this is a big deal to
me I mean if Sam warshaw if I found out
Sam warshaw went behind my back and
spent twenty five thousand dollars
there'd be an atom bomb that went off
you would see the explosion I'm just
saying there'd be a little little fire
there'd be Birds little birds chirping
around his head because I would have
knocked him out
so but I I kind of think it might been
more likely you that would do that than
him though you know what that's probably
true because I am the spender he is the
saber he's Mr deliberate yeah he is
which is even more reason if he did that
I would have gone off on him but it's
it's what you said these little things
it makes me think of that that scripture
that says a little eleven the only time
that we've even come close to that at
our house and we did come in the early
days we had lots of arguments about
money in fights was when I was so
overbearing I know you can't imagine
that happening that Sharon didn't feel
like she had a vote yeah and she will
tell you at about year seven of our
marriage she felt like she got her voice
yeah is the way she says it and she
never lost it since I'll just tell you
but um her voice but her voice but I got
my voice and um and yeah but it was she
got her vote yeah and uh and and from
then on she's kind of had two but um to
make up for the Lost Years but that's a
thing if you don't feel like you're you
have a a voice in the thing or you can't
make a lot you can't you can't get there
in a discussion then someone spouse
tends to go off and hide stuff and do
things and that's not an indication it's
not a money problem that's a
relationship that's right that's right
relationship problem and it wasn't it
wasn't my house too Sam I'm just
admitting just like you but I'm just old
and it was a long time ago yeah that's
the only difference so
um don't be mad at us we love you that's
why we're picking on you but I would fix
those things in my house because they're
costing you over the rest the scope of
the rest of your life millions of
dollars if you don't fix them this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire backed catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show but we help people
build wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
Jade Washington Ramsey personality is my
co-host today the phone number here is
AAA
825-5225 that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five starting this
hour off is Lisa in Ogden Utah hi Lisa
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you I'm so excited to get your
advice I've been binge watching shows
trying to get an answer to my question
now I get to talk to you we'll try how
can we help
all right uh 14 years ago I joined the
workforce after a divorce and took
Financial Peace that was offered through
my company and I've been playing with it
off and on and should have stuck with it
because three years ago I married
amazing man and we bought a home and
I've been slamming money down into our
401k to retire in five years and just
realized I probably shouldn't be doing
that and paying the house up
okay do you have any other debt
I have no doubt 20 000 in an emergency
fund a hundred thousand Ira 420
000 in a 401k
our principal payment is only a thousand
and sixty five on the home so I was
wondering I've been putting in 25 in the
401K 13 in Company stock and I was
thinking maybe I better just move all
that and start paying the house
well yeah I mean the way we would teach
it is to follow the baby steps in order
so you're above and beyond the 15 that
we would say for baby step four and I'm
guessing baby step five isn't a deal
saving for a kid's college so after that
we're on to baby step six and in this
case we would chunk all of that extra
money onto the mortgage because we want
you to have it paid off home and then
after that think about all of the money
that you could invest into retirement
after the home is paid off so what does
he make
he's at 55 000 and I'm at 115. 115 did
you say yes okay so one question is I
only have five years left I don't
contribute I don't care okay here's what
you you have more than that if you keep
working
um if you're going to retire in five
years that's different but um you got
420 000 in there when you get to
retirement age how old are you
YouTube okay all right so I do have the
hundred thousand Ira we could take out
okay well and you've got 420 as well uh
so you've got 520 what's the balance on
the mortgage
226 000. okay with 170 000 income so
here's the thing
we know when you get to your golden
years if we named that 70
or whatever that you want to have a paid
for house and a large Nest Egg both
agreed
yes we don't want to have a large nest
egg and a big mortgage and we don't want
to have a paid for house and no Nest Egg
we want both agreed
yes okay and what you're doing now is
you're only working on one which is kind
of what your your alarm system went off
wisely so so we would tell you to put 15
percent
of your income of 170 000 into
retirement plans of some kind in good
mutual funds everything above that
and so that's what
that's about twenty five thousand
dollars a year
okay everything
yeah everything above that goes on the
mortgage until the mortgage is paid off
which tells me your mortgage is gonna be
paid off in about three or four years
you'd probably still work a year or two
after that and max out everything but
here's the trick okay you if you're if
you're 520 000 is invested in good
mutual funds and it's averaging ten
percent or more it will double without
any contribution to it any additional
contribution it will double about every
seven years
so you said you're 62 right
yes so you're 520 becomes a million
forty
when you're 69. if you don't add
anything to it
wow and I'm telling you to continue to
add 15 to it and still get your house
paid off in about three or four years
and so and then it'll double again that
million will be two million seven years
after that which will be 76 years old
and all this time your house is being
paid for oh and by the way we've got
more money than that because you've also
added over this next five years at least
15 percent of a hundred and seventy
thousand so you have done a great job
all we're doing is just tuning just a
little bit just just tweaking the sound
just a little so it sounds a little
different okay
okay great I will do it yeah you're 90
on path all we're doing is a slight
change to get both things accomplished
in the sooner times that makes sense
bye
a question about life insurance real
quick all right obviously term insurance
goes up as you age so hopefully
insurance goes up as you age
month premium for a 200 000 policy my
husband's paying about 50 for a hundred
thousand policy do we need life
insurance
if he dies today
are you okay financially
yeah I'd like for you to get that house
paid off
it's so continue playing I'd probably
I'd probably keep it a couple more years
if you die today is he okay yeah you can
make it you got a half a million dollars
right
and an income and you know and some
Equity so you'll make it you're not
gonna starve to death you're going to be
a starving Widow on the corner right but
but by the way a hundred thousand
dollars or 200 000 I'm not gonna stop
that from happening anyway that's not a
lot of money but the good news is it's
about the balance of the mortgage so I
might keep it for two more years until
we get that mortgage paid way down but
when that mortgage is starting to reach
zero I'm dumping it
great idea
awesome I'm very excited thank you so
much well thank you for calling in we
appreciate getting to tune up on an old
FPU grad so you can fall off the wagon
as long as you're holding on to the end
that's right I mean nobody nobody's
perfect for all the time sometimes you
need a good kick in the butt to get
yourself back on the path yeah she
didn't even need that just a slight
course correction a little step you know
here's the things you know what the
moral of that story is some people are
doing
it's interesting there's kind of almost
there's probably several types of people
but two come to mind right now some
people are doing better than they think
they're doing yes and others aren't
doing nearly as good as they think
they're doing that's the other thing
that's true so that's true there's a
little bit of both there's probably a
third or fourth type but at least those
two come to mind right now that's what's
going on no she's doing a good job yeah
and uh you know a late in life marriage
or remarriage uh it's got its own issues
own problems own processes and they've
still navigated that so very well done
very very well done all right open
phones here if you want to talk about
your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five by the way if you
would help us out we would appreciate
you
um if you like the show
subscribe click the Subscribe or follow
button leave a review a five-star review
mama said if you ain't got nothing nice
to say don't say nothing at all I know
that's right leave us a five-star review
and share if you're a podcaster or
YouTube or whatever share it and if
you're listening on talk radio or
watching us on TBN let people know that
we're here and that they can come and
watch and listen and learn
hey you're the best advertisement we've
got and that's what we're here for is to
help you so help us spread the word boys
and girls this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Jade warshaw Ramsay personality is my
co-host today take tickets are going
really fast for our Building Wealth live
event tour we have four more stops on
the tour and you don't want to miss this
we're going to have a blast meeting you
guys on the road signing books taking
pictures answering your questions
sharing all the ways you can control
your money and live and give like no one
else now listen uh a lot of you are
doing these things you're listening to
the show you're engaged in this process
when we come to your city it's like your
pep rally it's your chance to come and
get jacked up again some of the stuff
you're here you've heard before that
kind of a thing but it's just a review
it's a pep rally it's your team and
you're on the team that's simple
February 16th uh just a couple weeks
you're going to catch me Rachel Cruz
George Campbell and Jade warshaw in
Indianapolis Feb 16. August Austin Texas
uh February 23rd Ken Coleman Dr John
deloney and Jade warshaw and me April
24th I'll be in Salt Lake City with
Rachel Cruz George Campbell and
Christina Ellis and our final stop of
the tour is Anaheim on May 2nd with me
Ken Coleman Dr John deloney and
Christina Ellis tickets are 49 starting
there and you can get a four pack
starting at 175 which you would pay for
one ticket for you to go to a concert or
something so there you go come out it's
just going to be that evening when we're
there we're gonna have a lot of fun
together we're gonna laugh you're gonna
go away going I can do this I've got
hope bring some of your friends who are
doubters the tickets are so inexpensive
people bring friends very often as a
method of converting them so here we go
ramseysolutions.com events The Building
Wealth live tour February 16th
Indianapolis Austin Texas February 23rd
24th Salt Lake City of April and May 2nd
in Anaheim ramseysolutions.com events
get your tickets now
Paige is with us page is in Atlanta
Georgia hi Paige welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi thanks so much
sure what's up
okay so my fiance and I are getting
married at the end of this year we're
cash flowing the wedding and our
honeymoon cool um and we're very excited
about that
um he has a car lease that we need to
get him out of in February of next year
and I we have a couple different options
for how to kind of go about that and I
wanted to see if you could help us
figure out what would be the best
solution okay
so so to buy out his lease it's going to
cost 24
um I get a cash bonus every year through
my job
um in february-ish mid-February
um the past two years it's been fifteen
thousand dollars so after taxes I get 10
000 take homes
um my car is paid for and Kelly Blue
Book has it valued around twelve
thousand dollars so my question is
should we sell my car to either use that
as a down payment on the 24 000 and then
have him make payments on the lease that
he's going to buy
um should we use the 12 000 from selling
my car to get him into a twelve thousand
dollar car and then use my bonus that I
get next year to get me a car or should
we not put anything down to buy out his
car and then use my bonus next year to
towards student loan debt that we have
Okay so
what is happening in February is the
lease up
yes the lease expires next February okay
all right is he over on his miles
no I don't think so is he torn up the
car or wear and tear
no it's in really good condition okay so
that means you can toss them the keys in
February
yes and hand them the car
yeah and you have ten thousand dollars
and he he will need a car correct
yes okay and what's your incomes
um so he makes ninety thousand and then
I make sixty seven thousand um I get
overtime so I make a little bit more
than that each year
hope you guys either one of you have any
other debt
we both have student loan debt okay how
much
he has ten thousand dollars and I have
twenty eight thousand dollars
Okay so 38. and we need a car and we
have ten thousand so we need forty eight
thousand and you make 170.
okay and you're cash flowing the wedding
what are you spending on the wedding
we're shooting for 25.
um the original plan was for 20 000 but
just with prices and inflation
everything it's gotten a little more
expensive than we had originally planned
okay let me tell you what I just heard
okay
I heard that between the two of you you
make a hundred and seventy thousand
dollars a year
okay yeah we're planning out a whole
year from now
and to be 100 debt free and buy a ten
thousand dollar car and pay for the
twenty five thousand dollar wedding you
need seventy five thousand dollars in
one year
making making one hundred and seventy
thousand
yes
does that not sound doable to you
it totally does see I think you have 100
debt free he has a ten thousand dollar
car and you paid cash for the wedding by
this time next year
yes the wedding the wedding is on
November of this year so we'll be done
by then I know
and so you're gonna do the wedding and
uh you've got that bonus coming about
the time that his car goes away so what
I'm saying is by the time you get to
February the student loans ought to be
gone and the wedding should be paid for
and then when you get your bonus he
tosses them the keys and you go buy ten
thousand dollar car with the ten
thousand dollars your bonus
okay so we should be paying our student
loans now and getting as much of that
out of the way as possible you make a
hundred and seventy thousand dollars a
year you need seventy five thousand
dollars a year to do all three things
buy a ten thousand dollar car pay off
the student loans and do the wedding
unless I did my math wrong
seventy five thousand dollars will do
all three of those
38 000 in student loans plus ten
thousand dollars for the car is forty
eight I rounded it to 50 25 on the
wedding that's 75. you with me yes yes
Jade am I what am I missing uh you're
right on track I think that she's still
understanding what that's going to mean
which is that yeah you ain't doing
nothing both you and your fiance are are
living on more or less nothing so that
you can accomplish this all this eating
out and Instagram life is done nothing
your broke friends are gonna think you
joined a cult but you're going to be a
hundred percent debt free and you're
going to turn in the stupid fleece car
in February and be driving two ten
thousand dollar cars and zero student
loans and you paid cash for your 25 000
wedding so I don't care what your stupid
broke friends think and let me challenge
you on that wedding
don't trick yourself into saying oh
because inflation or oh because this it
went up it went up because you didn't
say no you gotta yes exactly that like
you set the budget and you stick to your
budget and if that means that you have
to change plans or go with a different
vendor or go a different route do that
instead of saying well but you know I
had to up the budget because of
inflation just don't do that just set
your budget and stick to it and if you
don't set a budget on a wedding and
stick to it it will destroy you it will
double sure it'll double sure enough
it's real it is real so real we have big
parties all three Ramsey kids I got
married we had huge weddings I love a
big wedding I don't mind people spending
money on weddings they got the money if
you got the money and she's paying cash
for it so I did not diss her about that
but you're exactly right
um that the stinking emotions yeah
people will justify anything for one day
it's one day and and I'm all about
having a good party oh I am too I mean
have a good party but it is one day and
you've got this whole lifetime ahead of
you I don't want people going broke over
their wedding or thinking it's the last
time they're ever going to get to
celebrate anything yeah yeah you know
what I mean my husband and I got married
we paid cash for the wedding it was a
great wedding and then on our 10-year
anniversary you know what we did Dave
anything you want we had it again we
renewed our vows and we did it even
bigger oh there you go because we paid
cash for it anything you want anything
you want so that's the thing page if you
add it up 75 000 out of a hundred and
seventy thousand in a one year period of
time February to February sounds very
doable to me very good very a lot
there's lots of room in there but you're
gonna stop all your 401ks you're gonna
stop eating out and not planting
anything big you're doing three things
get free debt free wedding debt free
student loans pay cash for a ten
thousand dollar car toss them the keys
on the stupid fleece and don't get
fleeced again this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Craig
is with us hey Craig how are you hi Dave
greater happy to be here we're honored
to have you sir where do you live a
Phoenix Arizona oh fun very cool how
much debt have you paid off 374 408
dollars wow how long did this take
1638 days
638 days what's that come out to be a
little over four and a half years but
who's counting yeah okay all right wow
all right man oh man oh man and what was
your range of income over 1638 days it
started about
um 40 000 got up to about 200 way to go
cool what do you do for a living
um I own a legal document until every
business okay how'd you get your income
up so far
well
um when I took everything over and
did everything I could to drive
businesses as much as I can
um it worked yeah yeah it worked I I
didn't hire anybody on I took the role
of about four to five people I would say
just worked all the time yeah like a lot
of hours a lot you said when you took
everything over did you buy the business
I did I bought the business okay I
worked for it for about
um I want to say five or six years
before I took everything over okay wow
good for you so what kind of debt was
three hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars um it was a little bit of uh
credit cards a little bit of a car loan
and about 360
000 was the business loan oh okay from
buying the business correct okay but now
it makes 200 a year and you have no debt
at all
um yeah yeah pretty close I have a
mortgage but yeah that's next okay all
right well done sir thank you very well
done congratulations what happened to
make you go on this journey you know so
many people would take on business debt
and just go well it's it's the business
it's not me they'd be wrong in that but
what made you
say I'm gonna tackle this so I'd say it
started about eight or nine years ago
um I was renegotiating my lease with my
apartment complex and they were making
it to a point where it was I couldn't
afford it at the time
and um I was thinking to myself man it'd
be a lot easier to deal with this if I
didn't have a car payment or how great
would it be if I didn't even have to pay
rent it was my biggest expense what if
that didn't exist
fast forward a couple years and I'm
delivering papers at night and listening
to your show and I learned that those
things are optional I don't need to have
a car payment I don't need to have a
mortgage payment at some point my time
debt is
optional and so starting to get a little
bit more serious about it but not super
into it
um I stopped using credit cards but for
the most part
um didn't really create a budget and
then things didn't get very serious
until
one night I had to fill a prescription
for about fifty dollars and I didn't
have the money for it
and
that was the point where I decided that
that was it this is never going to
happen again
um I'm never going to worry about
filling a prescription I'm never going
to worry about going hungry I'm never
going to worry about my rent or or a
mortgage like this is over and I
resolved that
um I was going to get this completed as
fast as I possibly could
that's an interesting
well I mean you did you did perfectly uh
but it's an interesting process I never
thought about it that way first
Revelation was
um this is optional it's not required
that I stay a slave my whole life and
then you went from optional to pissed
off
and said I'm not living like this
and that was the next step was this
healthy anger yeah and so but but in
order for the anger to kick in the you
first had to realize this it doesn't
have to be this way right and then
you're like no it really is not going to
be this way you know it's like there was
a progression there you see what I'm
talking about that was interesting very
very insightful very cool good for you
man thank you sir you have worked your
butt off
yeah there were a lot of um I think
12-hour days was a minimum yeah
um there is a solid six eight week
period where there were 16 hour days
yeah
I was it worth it
um did not have that hanging over my
head anymore why did you not drag it out
three more years and just take it easy
I think you did right by the way but I'm
just curious for other people so I think
that would be probably the natural or
perhaps even instinctual option to go
with
um it'd be wrong but I'm just wondering
why you didn't yeah it
I think it comes down to my why
I
I it's a little bit selfish but I want
to walk the earth I don't want to be
beholden to any one person or something
that I don't want to naturally be
spending my time doing after doing this
I'm so guarded about my time because
it's so precious I usually usually I
mean the last four and a half years I
haven't had very much of it
so I want to spend that how how I want
to do it amen oh I like it I like it too
you're speaking my language right now
Craig uh all of that it's just it's that
that a different sort of freedom and I
love what you said about culture is
telling you you need debt you need this
to survive and you said I don't think I
do and I don't think I want that and I I
just love that So for anybody watching
tell them what's what's the one thing
that you've learned on this journey that
that you've taken into your life and
it's like from now on this is
this is that thing what is it
well
I think I wouldn't be doing it justice
if I only said one uh sorry hit me with
a couple sure yeah I think the budget
was pretty critical to doing everything
I don't think there was a way to do it
without a road map
um I would tell people to find ways to
stop trading your time for money and
trade your work for money
I was able to double up on a lot of my
work it would have been impossible if I
had a finite amount of time to trade for
money
um and then that why I think that why
was
a big driving force yeah yeah well done
sir who was your biggest cheerleaders
um well my brother and sister were there
through the the whole way
um I inspired both of them to to get out
of debt my brother is still working on
it my sister actually uh graduated
college debt free she paid all in cash
wow
um she just paid off her car so she's
completely done
um Greg my uh my right hand man at the
office he he was there for me the whole
way
um for you my girlfriends with me here
today all right yeah helping me with
that very cool good job man thanks sir
very very proud of you here impressive
young dude well done well done well done
three hundred and seventy four thousand
dollars and 1638 days you gotta love it
all right we've got the live and give
bundle for you the financial or The
Total Money Makeover book The Financial
Peace University uh membership for a
year and of course the baby steps
millionaires book you're on your way to
that one for sure and um you'll have
those to read and or give or whatever
you want to do with them thank you for
making the trip all the way to Nashville
and we appreciate getting to hang out
with you all the way from Phoenix it's
fun thank you for having me very very
well done all right Craig from Phoenix
Arizona
374 thousand dollars paid off in 1638
days making 40 all the way to 200 100
debt free except the house got his
business paid off it's all about it now
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one
[Music]
this is how it's done
well done well done well done I love it
I love it he's a thoughtful guy he
he thinks differently and I love that
well you know uh if you don't think
differently you're not going to be
different and you don't want to be
normal in this culture today I know
that's right normal is broke yeah almost
broke and we don't want to hang out with
that we don't want to be that and you
know you're going to be who you hang out
with so be careful about that because
they'll tell you that is not optional
and he decided it's optional that's a
great word for that I've not put that
word on that I wrote it down I was like
that's good
debt debt is optional you don't have to
live like that very well played you know
the other thing that's kind of going
around right now is this idea that I
don't want to work much
uh so I'm gonna in air quotes work from
home which means I don't plan to work
much
or I'm going to uh quiet quit or I'm
going to do all that you know the
laziness I can't say that has become
popular
is quite the opposite of old Craig over
here yeah it is Craig's on fire man he's
getting it yeah he's getting it
um yeah meanwhile what's what's being
lazy getting you never met mediocrity
turning into success yet uh and this guy
right here he's successful well done
Craig proud of you man very proud of you
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day Ephesians 6 10
finally be strong in the Lord and in his
mighty power
Muhammad Ali said it this way he who is
not courageous enough to take risks will
accomplish Nothing in life well there
you go
Jade Washington Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Justin is in Colorado
Springs hey Justin what's up
hey Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve how can I help
well hopefully you take it easy on me
and I won't be a bad segment on a
YouTube or something so if you're ready
I'll go ahead
we'll try
um well I'm uh basically I'm looking to
um I need to make some more money
long-term wealth wise and I have an idea
of where to start but I'm I kind of want
to get your
um you know advice on that so if you
need me to give you some just Basics I
can well what's your question I mean
what are you talking about
um I'm looking to build a little bit
more long-term wealth and I feel like me
and my wife are a little bit behind how
old are you
32. oh yeah you're never gonna make it
you're so old oh my gosh what's your
household income
um household income let's see we're
about 230 230 000. oh my Justin
yes if you're not gonna make it then I'm
screwed
well I and that's mostly the wife I'll
have to give her most of the credit but
uh
um but yeah we and we're big we've just
been saving honestly and I think it's
been time in our lives where we need to
start making some more riskier moves
because I just looked at our statements
on our savings account and we're getting
just it's laughable our interest rate on
our savings account what do you how much
do you have in that savings account
um liquid we have enough savings account
about 240 000. okay yeah and it's making
one percent or something
yeah we got like 180 or 200 bucks every
month and it's just I was trying to tell
my wife this is we got to do something
else and uh together I do agree that
needs to change yeah all right so what
we teach folks Justin to uh build wealth
and to lay a foundation to build that
wealth with is a process called the baby
steps that's right okay so do you guys
currently have any debt
um the only debt we have is a 27 000
truck loan okay so when we walk through
the baby steps baby step one which you
have this is one thousand dollars saved
you don't have to worry about that
because you got that laying around uh
after that we're gonna pay off all of
our debt except the mortgage using the
debt snowball you've only got the One
debt right you can pay it off today pull
it out of your savings you're debt free
today the next thing after that is
you're gonna go to baby step three which
is getting three to six months saved now
and you guys a situation uh does do both
of you guys work
yeah we're both working okay uh solid
type work or are you seasonal is there
any reason that you would want six
months above three months of expenses no
um we just had a little one but other
than that she's still working I'm
working and she's a nurse practitioner
and I'm a power lineman so okay so for
fun for fun let's call your emergency
fund fifty thousand dollars yeah now the
emergency fund Justin does not earn
money it's there for protection of the
things that do earn money
so you said you had how much in savings
200 about 240 000 total two four in a
liquid savings okay 240. okay so we just
spent 27 and paid off your car and then
I spent 50 for the emergency fund I
allocated some of that so that's 75 out
of that so we're around
140 right now left over okay with me and
you got a little one now what we do
after that after you've got the
emergency fund in place and you're debt
free but the house then we start working
what we call Baby Steps four five and
six simultaneously
4 is I want you to start investing 15
percent of your household income into
good mutual funds in retirement accounts
401ks roths Roth IRAs with a match
without a match whatever you've got that
you can do up to 15 no more than 15
percent going into retirement but I want
that much going in there and so that's
about out of your monthly budget that's
not out of this Inc out of this savings
but out of your monthly budget that's
going to amount to about thirty thousand
thirty five thousand dollars a year okay
okay out of your out of your man you got
a really good income that alone if you
do that in good mutual funds will make
you a multi-millionaire when you are 65.
if you just do that and we're not going
to stop there okay but if you just do
that you're going to be a
multi-millionaire then
once you're doing that now we go on to
baby step five which is kids college now
I would sit down with an investment
professionals click smartvestor pro at
ramsesolutions.com and uh start a kids
college fund for your new little one and
you can throw 10 grand in there
[Music]
is that in good mutual funds
what is it called a 520 uh
but is it mutually fine yeah is it
Mutual I'm not sure I'll have to I'll
have to double check it out you need to
make sure it's in good mutual funds just
like the 15 in baby step four is then
baby step five is we're going to
concentrate on baby step six because
we're going to concentrate on paying off
the home next before we do additional
investing beyond the 15 because when you
don't have a house payment or anything
you got so much stinking money to build
wealth with it's unbelievable okay so
I'm gonna throw that other 100 100 and a
quarter if you don't need to buy a car
or something else out of it that you may
want to set back something if you got a
purchase coming but if you don't have a
purchase coming I'm throwing all of that
at the house what's your mortgage
balance
um we owe about 220 I believe on it
amazing I love this so we throw 120 at
it we got 100 we got a hundred left and
you're going to be debt free house and
everything in two to three years when
you're 35 years old what's this house
worth
um I think the it would just we just
enlisted just off realtor.com it's
probably not very accurate but about 450
460. okay so in three years when it's
paid for it's worth 600. by then what
I'm outlining you're going to have three
or four hundred in your retirement
accounts I'm what we're outlining is
going to have you to have your first
million dollar net worth you'll be a
millionaire by 36 or 37.
oh come on I can't oh boy I thought this
was gonna go downhill no this is very
good Justin
I was worried that we weren't investing
enough right now because we only have
we're not on Cade we don't do okay
you're not you need to be putting 15
aside and this money doesn't need to be
laying in savings but it's not it's not
something you need to go the Woodshed
over you're making a lot of money and
you're not spending it all way to go
yeah you know that's awesome to my wife
oh that's awesome I mean she's awesome
then you guys so the bottom line is you
don't need money laying there like that
120 not working any harder than it is
I'm going to throw it at the house so it
works a little harder and then let's
just the next big thing it doesn't mean
we have to live on beans and rice
because you're doing really well but I
just want you to be very intentional any
money Beyond retirement beyond that 15
that you can find in your budget that
you don't need to have a reasonable life
before you put it into a savings account
again let's just chunk it on the
mortgage and finish that mortgage off
you got it yeah 33 000 a year finishes
that mortgage off in three years
okay and you make 200 and something
that's right yeah I mean you guys could
get you're just doing so good yeah
you're a YouTuber you're a YouTube cut
but it's a good one
yeah okay
I was a little worried because you know
I just started getting into a little bit
more and it's like if you're not
investing when you're younger you know
and well you are and all we did here is
fine tune the smart you already took you
already had smart and we just added the
icing on the cake to make it run just a
little bit smoother okay yeah and I was
where you're gonna get mad at me did we
go we did just get a recently a nice
decent truck but uh it was we call it
the baby mobile and I'm not mad at you
but never take out another car payment
car payment is middle class thinking
okay pay cash for your cars the rest of
your life
okay it'll make you it'll make you think
about your cars different
oh for sure okay awesome well that's
great then I thought uh you're gonna pay
it off today right
um yes I'm gonna go to the wife right
now and tell her what you said and then
we'll see what she says okay all right
all right hang on I'm gonna send you a
copy of the book baby steps millionaires
because you are on track to be one very
soon my friend that's exciting he's a
good one he's a good one and I love that
it's showing that it's not too late if
you're in your 30s and you're just now
getting around to investing I think I
think you're gonna be all right you'll
be okay well and interesting how they
were working together yeah I'm not going
to pay it off till I talk to her but
then we're going to pay it off there we
go I like it yeah we're not yelling at
you no you're a big one not a bit that
puts the sour the Ramsey Show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]